hey youtubers is Charlie orphan black is
back I totally didn't catch season one
till after it airs so I didn't do videos
for that but I'm gonna do weekly videos
for each new episode of season two so in
case you're not caught up I'm gonna do a
super quick recap of season 1 before I
do my top 5 moments if you are finding
me for the first time I do a ton of BBC
shows like Doctor Who Sherlock and now
obviously orphan black be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's gonna
be a lot of fun so right away here's my
super quick recap of clone Club season 1
we're introduced to the dyad clone
conflict via Sarah and even though the
perspective shifts based on which clone
is in a scene I always thought of her as
being the main protagonist of the series
Rachel and dr. leekie are essentially
the main villains you know until we find
out about Helena who kind of becomes a
second big villain but that only really
comes out near the end of this season
the diet is essentially trying to
advance human genetics and make it so
that they can own they can literally own
human DNA clone DNA really but
essentially it's implied that big
pharmaceutical companies will start
owning people like you and I would own
possessions really bad for everyone
because all the clones are essentially
like a beta trial that the dyad is
running they've been monitoring them but
then Helena comes in and basically tries
to start taking them all out killing
them one by one so think of the dyad
villains as an allegory for Big Pharma
pushing the idea of self-directed
evolution through science and Helena at
the other extreme as the religious
zealot who's completely opposed to the
idea of evolution the clones are
essentially the collateral damage in the
war between Helena and the dyad so they
have to band together to survive which
is where we get clone Club so now that
we're caught up on season 1 let's break
into the episode so here my top 5
moments careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet though but number 5
Allison go shopping I love Allison so
much I have a feeling that she's gonna
be my favorite clone this season the
shopping scene was just hilarious and in
case you missed it every time there was
an Allison scene after this they used
the same funny music cues like the music
would go from really serious to light
and funny meaning that all the comedy in
this episode and you know maybe as we go
on through the season is gonna come from
Allison's character and all her scenes
you get this real sense that Allison is
a reluctant participant she's the only
one with the traditional home situation
so even when she's Skyped in for clone
later in the episode you could see her
ironing her family's laundry in the
background it was just hilarious but now
we have to talk about her play number
four Alison's amazing play the play
itself is just a really funny meta story
for Alison's role in the fight against
the diet as well as that callback to
season one you know a lot cleaning up
unfortunate bodies I love how they
called back to Felix's cats moment about
the name of the play as in this play is
definitely not cats who else actually
listened to the lyrics they were singing
it was all about plasma leaking on the
floor and cleaning up blood it kind of
hearts back - Cosima and Delphine with
the blood samples and as much as I think
of this as being Sarah story with the
other clones just you know kind of
passing through it that's really not
true orphan black is kind of like the
overstory of all the clones stories so
that every time we jump to a scene with
a different clone
there's always references to what's
happening with the other clones so
you'll never see a scene with a clone
that doesn't reference another scene
with another clone they're all connected
at a fundamental level so all the
stories inside an episode have to be
connected at a fundamental level and the
play is just a funny meta way of showing
that so for instance the play some of
the lyrics talk about cleaning up
unfortunate bodies you know like Sarah
having to clean up Koch's body it gets
super confusing when you think about the
idea of having each scene call back to
another scene with a different clone and
maybe even something that happened in
season one so high fives - the writers
for keeping the story so complex and so
interesting you know without getting
buried under its own weight
number three Sarah tricks Daniel with
Alison like I said Alison amazing in
this episode but this was one of the
funniest attempted abductions I've ever
seen it was hard to tell if Alison
actually knew what was gonna happen
because it seems like she was surprised
she was skyping in while Sarah was
planning on how to get into the dyad but
I think they just cut her out of the
conversation whenever they were setting
her up as a distraction to get Daniel
away quick side note though I did feel
like this was a really good anti
kidnapping PSA even though they
eventually did get her into the van so
in case anyone ever tries to abduct you
one blow your rape whistle and - at the
same time pepper spray the [ __ ] out of
anything in your field of vision
even though Daniel did let her go they
totally deserve to get maced in the face
Alison did say that she wasn't keeping
guns at home anymore but I was
surprised that she didn't have one on
her and I thought it was kind of funny
that she you know accepted Daniels
apology as she slid out of the van kind
of gave him the finger on the way out so
getting a little bit more serious
number two dr. leekie speech at the dyad
it was a lot going on at the party but
it was Leakey's speech that really
interested me
he basically speechify the entire
history of the dyad and how far their
organization reaches around the world so
it was started in 1918 and now it's got
labs in over a hundred countries with
over 27,000 employees is essentially the
personification of big faceless Pharma
you know the big faceless villain even
though they do technically have faces
remember Lee keys mission is all about
self-directed evolution you know
something that ties into the philosophy
of neolution is amiss kind of takes on
this religious aspect that's the real
reason the clones exist and why they
called Kira a biological goldmine leekie
believes she's the next stage of
evolution the clones on the other hand
are technically imperfect because
they've been breaking down in case you
missed it though whenever Rachel was
meeting with the Koreans they actually
literally spell out their plan for
owning human DNA like owning people and
my number one moment
Helena is still alive this was like the
major WTF of the episode sarin art put
the pieces together after he kind of
explains what was going on with the
diner attack but I liked that they
called them religious zealots they look
creepy even when I thought they were
just working for Rachel
I mean who buttons that top button
without wearing anything around their
neck Matt Smith's doctor would be
rolling in his grave Helen this plan
though seems pretty simple just kill all
the clones right now I don't think she
has any grand design like dr. leekie she
just literally wants them all dead I
don't think she wants to hurt Kira
though but she might kill mrs. s while
this was all going on I checked the
orphan black hashtag on Twitter and my
feed was just littered with Helen O's in
all caps just all Helena all caps but
let me know what your favorite moment
from the episode was you know was it
Allison's hilarious play or the Helen
reveal or something else and let me know
who was your favorite cologne in the
episode obviously mine was Allison so
before I get to my review here's a
couple more really important plot points
that I didn't want to include in my you
know top moments but that are really
important that we need to keep up with
first off Cosima and Delphine
is playing who the best Cosima is
definitely on team clone Club but
there's this whole Spy vs spy thing
going on with Delphine working with
leekie to get Cosima on their side I
think underneath it all Delphine isn't
as genuine as say you know art who's
trying to get Sarah to trust him when
you think about it Delphine didn't
realize she was kissing Sarah till after
the whole run-in with leekie you'd think
that if you were in love with someone
and had been in a relationship you'd
know if the person you were kissing was
someone else Plus Sarah's hair wasn't
even the same maybe Delphine is just the
worst girlfriend ever though but as for
art I think he's gonna be a force for
good
even if he's technically not on Team
clone Club and the same goes for Paul
Paul's playing both sides but I think he
really does care about Sarah but I
really don't think any of these
relationships are gonna end well
you know Paul and Delphine overall I
gave the episode a solid a - it was an
amazing entry into season 2 especially
when you consider that the hardest job
the show has right now is topping itself
you know topping season 1 last year was
so good it's gonna be so hard to top
which is where Helena steps in you know
the WTF moment at the end I think part
of the solution to the problem and the
episode kind of explained it beautifully
or Rachel explained it beautifully is
that they go international season 1 on
the other hand was relatively
self-contained geographically remember
how rachel was asking Paul those
questions about speaking Mandarin and
going to Taiwan
this also kind of ties back into
leakiest speech about the diet having
offices all over the world the story of
season 2 is just gonna be told with a
much more global context the only thing
I thought could have been done better in
the episode was Felix's story he just
like Alison was a well of comedy they
used to drive the plot forward but
Allison scenes were so good that they
just made Felix seem like a throwaway
character this week like he was just
kind of like a silly fool although I do
kind of think of his archetype his
character as the fool not in a bad way
but let's talk about the clone Club
scenes real quick because sometimes
those are the most interesting I kind of
go into hyper aware mode whenever all
the clones are together in a scene I
kind of think of them as different
aspects of the Freudian psyche like one
clone is the it'd one is the ego and one
is the super-ego I guess you could also
think of it in terms of subconscious and
conscious minds but let me know if you
agree like when they're all together
they're a whole person they're like
pieces of a single person but let me
know what your final thoughts are on the
episode I'm really excited for this
season and like I said I'm gonna be
doing weekly videos so be sure to
subscribe to get it it's gonna be every
Saturday night that I'll be posting them
but tomorrow is all about Game of
Thrones so just to get you guys ready
here's my review of the last week's
episode and you can click here to get my
latest Doctor Who series 8 video thanks
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you